hey you guys we're doing another review
today
now this one is another kind of another
little bit
forgotten gem i feel like uh because
it's another one that really doesn't
come up in a lot of discussions
and sort of disappeared for a long time
um it was kind of recently rediscovered
and
got you know a nice blu-ray release and
everything like that but i feel like
you know for decades it's just kind of
been swimming around under the radar
which is really a shame because this is
actually like a really really good
like creepy old-school kind of
uh you know i don't want to say haunted
house because it's not exactly that but
it's just kind of like a creepy
almost like a jello film i want to say a
little bit but we'll get into that in a
bit
so this movie is called next of kin
and it came out in 1982. uh not to be
confused
with the patrick swayze movie also
called next of kin which i think came
out in 1989 two completely different
movies so please don't confuse them
so next of kin was made
in australia and it was directed by
tony williams who i think was a like did
tv commercials mainly
and i think this was only his second
film and i don't think he made any more
the shitty thing that happened with this
film is that i feel like it got a
theatrical release
in australia and it actually did well it
got nominated for some awards and stuff
like that i think it won like a best
editing award or whatever
but then um some various unfortunate
things happened where like one of the
uh the people that was financing the
production
like before the you know before the
release they died
and so there was all kinds of problems
with releasing it so it never got a
worldwide release
and i think it got a blu-ray in release
in australia
but never anywhere else until quite
recently in 2019
i ended up seeing it i think i could
because like i said i usually i like to
go
and check you know various lists of like
underrated horror films
from the 70s underrated horror films in
the 80s because i like to make sure
there's not any that i missed because
you know it's very easy for a lot of
them to kind of slip through the cracks
if you're not paying attention
so i saw this one on a list of
underrated 80s horror movies like a long
time ago
and then i was very happy to see that
shutter had added it and this was going
back like several months maybe even a
year
and i think as of this recording i think
it's even available for free on 2b as
well in the us
so if you want to watch it you can check
it out over there so as i said this
movie
quentin tarantino was actually a big fan
of it and that was one of the things
that
spurred its uh rediscovery i guess if
you want to call it that because he
um in his thing like not quite hollywood
he mentioned it
and he was talking about how it's a
shame that it wasn't um
more widely released because it would
have been one that was really remembered
from
that year and i mean 1982 was a great
[ __ ] year for horror movies i mean
[ __ ] man
you know the thing came out creep show
came out they were just like
poltergeists came out like tons of good
ones came out
but this one is actually really really
good and he compared it to
the shining and it does kind of have a
tone like that
there was a lot of australian movies
that came out in the 70s and 80s you
know what they call osploitation which
is very funny
but a lot of them were kind of like you
know mad max like post-apocalyptic type
of stuff
or there was like a lot of slashers and
some of those were good too
this movie next of kin it has a little
bit
of a slasher thing to it
but it's not you know it's got blood
it's got gore and stuff like that but
it's not
quite the same i mean it is very much
like the shining also
as i said it very much the way it's shot
reminds me a lot of a giallo
movie from that era or maybe from a
little bit earlier
it's just i don't know what it is
there's just something about the
aesthetic of it
you know the house where they shot it
you know these kind of close-ups
of people's faces with like the lighting
close-ups of like crystals and things
like that
so it really kind of gives me that vibe
and also the story is a little bit
jealou-like i want to say as well but
not so much like a straight up slasher
but it's more like
a mystery you know what i mean like
people turning up dead and it's a
mystery so he's doing it
and then like you find out the identity
later on
so what happens in this story you have
this woman this young woman named linda
and her mother has just died
and i guess that she has been living out
of town somewhere i think
i think she mentioned something about
being like a teacher or you know or
working with disabled children or
whatever
but her mom dies and she inherits this
massive
property this big house that her mom ran
as you know an elder care home
so she's kind of come back to the old
homestead i'm not sure what town it is
but it's kind of a real small like
remote
uh you know australian town and she
comes back there after several years to
sort of
not take over the uh management of the
place because they have people for that
but she's just coming back they're going
through her mother's things and like
deciding what she wants to do with the
proper she wants to sell it
um because she doesn't really seem to
want to stay in town to want to run it
but you know she's not cranky about or
anything like that but she's kind of
like well maybe i should sell it it's
you know it's
there's a lot of bills outstanding and
there's not that many
uh residents in there and i guess the
money is kind of messed up like the
finances are kind of messed up and she's
kind of stuck with it
so when she gets back there it's this
really really creepy
place and pretty much from the jump now
this
like i said this is kind of like a slow
burn in the same way that the shining is
it just i don't know there is really
something shining-esque about it just
i don't i don't know what it is i can't
really put my finger on it but it does
kind of
i don't think it takes that long to get
where it's going and it's not very long
um i do see some people like some other
reviews of it that i read that said it
was kind of slow but i didn't really
find it particularly slow
because i think it does uh a good job at
like foreshadowing like some kind of
creepy [ __ ]
so while linda is in the house and
there's you know all the
you know residents that are there and
there's a small staff as well and then
there's a bunch of other people in town
like there's this dude named barney
who's uh played by the same guy that
played
mick in wolf creek like many years later
but he's young in this
so you know if you're into like
australian film you've seen wolf creek
and you want to see this guy
young like in a good guy or like a
normal role then check it out so this
guy is kind of like somebody i just he's
not really her boyfriend but i guess
they were going out at some point
and then you know they kind of came up
and like reconnected or whatever
and uh so they're just [ __ ] buddies i
suppose and so they're kind of hanging
out
and you know everybody kind of in town
knows her and knew her mom because as i
said it's a small town
so she comes back and she's going
through her mom's stuff
and she finds a diary of her mother's
and her mom is starting to say like
stuff about weird [ __ ] going on
around the house um you know she's like
i keep seeing somebody outside
uh the taps you know keep turning on by
themselves
[ __ ] like that so you're kind of led to
believe that maybe this is a haunting
situation
and linda is kind of freaking out a
little bit because she's like some of
the same stuff has started happening to
her
like she'll she'll hear a noise and
she'll like leave the room
and then she'll come back into the room
and then like the candles will be lit or
some [ __ ] like that you know or she'll
see like a shadowed person like outside
in the rain or whatever and then like
when she goes out there they're gone so
as i said you
are beginning to think that maybe the
house is haunted or something of that
nature
now before any of the real bad [ __ ]
happens
they have like a new resident come who
is this woman in a you know
she's her i guess it's like her nephew
or son or something like that whoever it
is
uh brings her in this uh wheelchair
and it's this really bad storm like a
tree falls in front of the truck and
they have to you know kind of
get this woman up to the house like in a
rainstorm but she can't really walk and
all this other kind of [ __ ]
now there's kind of a little bit of
conflict too because
linda who now owns the place is kind of
having a little bit of a conflict with
connie who
has been running the place you know
since her mom died she's like the main
nurse or manager or whatever
linda said i thought we said that we
weren't going to get any new people
because i'm thinking about maybe selling
this place
and connie's like yeah but we need money
to pay the bills and blah blah blah so
there's this whole thing so this new
person shows up
so as i said it kind of goes on where
there's just like creepy [ __ ] there's
like creepy noises um
you know she sees people like like a
dude like out in the woods sometimes
like she sees him and then he's gone
uh candles being lit uh one time she
comes back to the house and sees
someone in her mother's red coat like
standing in her
bedroom window like she thinks she sees
it and
everybody seems to be telling her well
you know you're just tired and you're
upset because your mom died and you're
just like
imagining things and whatever and she
indeed she does seem to be maybe
she thinks she's kind of losing her
marbles a little bit but then like some
even more sinister things start to
happen in that
this poor old guy that lives there his
name is lance
and he's uh got his bath going one
morning and it's all kind of
the bathroom's all steamy and everything
and he goes to step in the bath
and there's already a dead old dude like
in the bathtub it's super creepy and uh
you know so the doctor comes and they're
kind of like oh well he must have just
had a heart attack in the bath and
drowned it's like so unfortunate but
it's an eldercare home
you know what are you gonna do it
happens so no one is all that upset
about it
and the creepy thing too is i guess
since this is a small town they have to
like keep the body in the house for a
little while until like the coroner or
whoever can come get it
and so the body is sort of in the house
just in this room they just
kind of tuck it in there and uh you know
so one night linda
is kind of hears a weird noise and she
goes into the room where it is and like
the sheet has come off of it and it's
like looking at her and it's like super
creepy
but it's just like all that other kind
of stuff so then as um
as linda like reads further and further
on into her mom's
diary she sees that all of these people
that were
residents there like these older people
keep turning up dead and they usually
turn up in the
bathtub you know that like they that
they drowned and she thinks that's
really weird and like i said she said
too that
you know the taps would be left on and
all this other kind of crap
and then you find out too later on that
when linda was a little girl
you know she had actually discovered one
of the dead bodies in the bathtub and
she i don't know if she didn't really
remember it
because she seems to have some
flashbacks of that so maybe she does
kind of remember it some of it's like
freaking around
so as it goes on there's also this girl
that turns up that's also kind of
hanging out with her sort of quasi
boyfriend
um you know he's always kind of got that
on the side or whatever
and they turn up to go to a party and
then the next day or a couple days later
one of the old guys like finds the
girl's beret
like in the fountain in front of the
[ __ ] and then
somebody pulls the girl's very
distinctive red sports car
up in front of the house like in the
middle of the day honks the horn
and then like takes off but linda is
like looking out there
and it looks like the girl is in the
passenger seat and then there's a dude
driving but she can't see who it is
so people keep turning up dead like
either the old people turn up dead in
the bathtub
or you know the girl turns up dead and
she actually kind of stumbles across her
body like out in the [ __ ] grounds
later on
so she's she's kind of having a thing
where she's not really sure
if this is like a haunted house type
thing or
if somebody's killing all these people
or
if she's just going nuts and she's
imagining it because
there's a whole thing too about her mom
having seen some of the same things and
her reading about it in the diary
and then a lot of people saying oh her
mom had you know mental issues or
something like that so she's thinking
well [ __ ] maybe i inherited that kind of
thing
and like i said i'm kind of explaining
it like that but the cool thing about
this movie
is that you know there's a lot of
dialogue there's stuff that's explained
through dialogue or through you know her
investigations like through old
paperwork in the house or whatever
but a lot of it is kind of conveyed
visually you know what i mean there's
not a lot of big
exposition dumps or anything like that
really which i think is really really
i mean it's a really well done a well
put together film there's some really
creepy
imagery in it and it's just really
unsettling like i just really like a lot
of the
you know as i said the very like giallo
esque
sort of cinematography to it it's just
great and i think the guy
the score is good too and the guy that
did the score i think was the original
drummer for
uh tangerine dream uh so i think they
used his score but like the score is
really good it's just a really
eerie it's just got a really eerie vibe
to it
i don't i'm not sure i don't know i was
going to say um
that i don't know if i want to spoil it
or not like what the who the killer is
or who the mystery is
but i mean this did come out in 1982 i
know maybe a lot of people haven't seen
it but then on the other hand uh when i
talked about the haunting of julia
i pretty much spoiled that one and you
know maybe a lot of people haven't seen
that one either
so i don't really know whatever but uh
yeah so
it turns out that she's not crazy
because initially she thinks that
um the doctor dr barton
because she finds out that all of these
old people that
uh her mom said drowned in the bathtub
like you know suspiciously
uh dr barton signed all of their death
certificates and said they died of
various other things like oh
arteriosclerosis or this one had a
cardiac arrest or this one that and the
other
and she's like hey my mom said they
drowned so he's making stuff up
so she begins to suspect that dr barton
and connie like the woman that manages
the [ __ ]
are like conspiring behind her back to
like kill these people for whatever
reason
but i think i'm not going to spoil it
but i'm i'm going to say that that's
kind of what you're led to believe
because like i said the two of them they
seem like they're
[ __ ] one thing connie and uh dr
barton because they're always like going
in the rooms and
you know what we weren't making out you
know it's that kind of thing so it does
kind of seem like they're
always sort of talking to one another
and it does seem kind of fishy that dr
barton had put his
name on the [ __ ] that's not exactly
what's happening
i don't think that they're conspiring
because
it ends up being somebody else but
i'm not saying that they might not know
about it or they might
because the person that is killing the
people is somebody that
is supposed to be dead but is not dead
so i'll just go that far
okay that's what i'll say but yeah so
this is a really really good flick like
i said i feel like it's gotten forgotten
about
i'm really happy to see that they did a
really nice
blu-ray release in 2019 so this finally
is
getting some recognition for being a
really really underrated
really good uh horror movie an
australian one that as i said
you know it kind of has aspects of
haunted house kind of like shining type
of stuff
and that it kind of has a little bit of
a slasher kind of thing too
too but more giallo-esque so it's very
much like a very european
sort of horror film kind of as i said
it's sort of a slow burn
but it's and it's real atmospheric it's
kind of
more about the atmosphere the whole just
the whole
building up of dread and it's just great
like set pieces and stuff like that it's
more about that than about
the characters although you do care
about linda and you care about what
happens to her and what the hell is
going on
but it's i just feel like the whole
atmosphere and the plot of it is more
important than
maybe the characters and stuff are so i
don't know but yeah so as i said there's
a blu-ray release
of this if you want to get it on
physical medium and i believe it is also
available on
to be you can watch it for free with
commercials
and at least in the us it is also
available to watch on
shutter as of this recording and i would
recommend you check it out if you're
really into
early 80s just kind of these creepy slow
burn ghost story type movies
and especially if you like australian
cinema from that time period
because this one it has some of the
hallmarks i guess of australian films
from that time period but it's also it's
totally its own thing it's like i said
it has more of a european vibe to it
than an australian vibe
but it still has a lot of australian
flavor to it you know what i mean
um but yeah it's definitely definitely
worth uh checking out
and uh that will do it for this
particular movie review and i will see
you guys
on the next one bye